Ось так виглядав Берлін на річницю
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в
Україну українці пройшли ходою центром
міста щоб висловити свій протест проти
російської агресії і масових вбивств
мирних мешканців в Україні
цю та десятки інших видовищних акцій за
останній рік у німецькій столиці
влаштувала громадська організація віча
днем народження організації що об'єднала
українську громаду в Берліні активісти
вважають 30 січня Минулого року саме
цього дня відбулася Перша акція під
назвою війна не має кордонів тоді вони
вимагали ввести ембергу на енергоносії з
Росії і припинити економічну та будь-яку
іншу співпрацю з РФ Це було дуже цікаво
би всі піднялися з цього есподу Який ще
працював тоді і буквально в прямому
сенсі цього слова всі люди не знайомі
одні між одним зібралися щоб робити віче
тобто таким дуже горизонтальним дуже
таким Тобто майже ніхто нікого не знав
до цього і це було дуже сильно в цьому
то бо зібрані були як за ціллю це
підтримка України це допомогти всіма
нашими можливими ресурсами за рік
існування віче трансформувалася тепер це
зареєстрована громад організація зі
своєю структурою якщо до
повномасштабного вторгнення метою
зібрань були демонстрації культурні
заходи та лекції з історії України то
після пріоритетом стали організація
масових демонстрацій та збір
гуманітарної допомоги
[музика]
коли ти приходиш на акцію дуже важливо
розуміти тобто що це зараз час говорити
про суб'єктність України цього не було
цього не було дуже довго цього не було
грицькій конференції цього не було в
2014 році 91-му році коли люди приходили
І хотіли робити проекти Україну поміщали
в проект остороко просто надаючи
суб'єктність нарешті наш голос час до
часу чують тобто і це дуже важливо якщо
ми хочемо жити в цьому світі
горизонтального так тобто рівності
віче і надалі залишаються волонтерською
організацією основна команда налічує
близько 19 людей але до роботи
організації долучається і громада А це
понад 200 людей організація
запам'яталася яскравими акціями деякі з
них виглядали як справжній перформанс я
пам'ятаю як
один німецький фотограф який часто
проходить нас фотографувати Потім поїхав
в Україну фотографував ну моїх знайомих
друзів і він їм розповідав що Боже ми
всі в захваті завжди як українська які
українські взагалі які українці
[музика]
яка в них велика уява
на 5 серпня ми виставляли 57 голів
Леніна сміттєвих пакетах А на фоні грала
всі 9 годин лекції рафа-леленкина
просвітницький геноцид проти українців
яку він вивелося 503 році
попри те що демонстранти отримують
підтримку з боку місцевої влади
організовувати демонстрації та акції для
українців не так просто складності
багато які раз пов'язані з цими якимись
мабуть на розумінням чи суб'єктності чи
чогось тобто я думаю найбільше такий
біль Для нас це 9 травня 8-9 травня коли
заборонили через кому українські та
російський прапор
тобто мене коли я мала там браслет
синьо-жовтого кольору я проходила повсу
цей советский меморіал
мене зупинила поліція сказала ви в
українській символіці Ви маєте це зняти
я таке це Браслет А через дорогу
буквально тобто чоловіки там де не
прапор футбо георгіївські стрічки я так
кажу але там порушення ну тобто ви ж
бачите він каже ну це ну я не за це не
відповідаю ось а коли підходиш там і
каже ну Георгіївська стрічка під це не
підпадає
теж коли ми бойкотували приїзд Діда
Мороза з Росії
до російського дому і коли ми тобто
реєстрували акцію я пам'ятаю як в нас
дуже далеко відпускали потім три рази
нас переміщали під час цієї акції і
останні це взагалі казала а станьте так
за будинком
Утім попри перепони віче продовжує
організовувати акції в німецькі столиці
реагують на потребу України у війні один
з потужних меседжів останніх місяців це
заклики до німецького уряду надати
необхідній Україні німецькі танки
Леопард 2
це було просто величезний момент і це от
в цьому випадку дуже чітко видно що ти
Краплю в океані але океан але океан
разом це дійсно це їх ця хвиля змін якби
наші Захисники та захисниці День і ніч
не клали життя те що ми робимо те що ми
можемо досягнути спільно з іншим
організаціями не тільки в Німеччині по
всьому світу було просто нереально
будь-яка наша невеличка маленька велика
перемога це все Завдяки ним Тому що люди
побачили що оцих вони дізналися умовно
про цей архетип Героїв Крут і
він триває і він росте і ми всі її
здобуваємо від нього
[музика]